[Music]
hello everybody my name is save Italian
aimer I'm the grill master resident at
the st. Louis chess club and welcome to
a weekly session of games you should
know by heart so welcome today where we
are actually having an exciting topic
and we are going to be looking at games
with the most beautiful last moves so
we're just going to look at the last
move well we're gonna also look at how
the players got to that last move but
the last move is going to be the cherry
okay so let's look at our first game
today
the first game was played a long time
ago and in 1800 was played by Alexander
MacDonald versus Louise a Charles LeBeau
donor yes now the day the game got a
nickname they the nickname of the game
is laid on a picnic and you will see why
so we're not going to were not going to
stop too much at the middle game but
they're going to look mostly at the last
move efore c5
ix 396 d4 we're in the Sicilian defense
pawn takes pawn takes an E 5 so we got a
specially curved right usually white
plays Knight to b6 trying to exploit the
d6 weakness but in this case white took
on c6 I think this position is already
equal Bishop c4 Knight of 6
Bishop cg5 Bishop e7 Queen e2 defending
the e4 pawn and now pawn to d5 starting
to advance the pawns Bishop took an f6
Bishop takes enough six
the bishop went to b3 so so far
why do you got a slightly black got a
slightly better position to bishops a
center but not so easy to win so let's
see what happened
Castle castle and a5 great move both Amy
get playing a4 and Bishop a6
he takes d5 Sita is d5 and now I play
rook to d1 very good good good answer
good answer to the threats both of them
because a foe loses to Bishop d5 and now
Bishop e6 is not so effective anymore so
black played d4 very strong very strong
pawns in the center not hanging not so
much because they are being supported
now here I played c4 and someone that I
don't like so much blocking blocking the
bishop
maybe maybe white should stop playing on
white squares like night night 2d 294
Knight to c4 and so on so c4 really
allows black to create those really
strong pass pawns
so let's see what happened Queen to b6
getting the Queen away from the D file
excellent move
Bishop c2 everybody can see the threat
but reg just played Bishop to b7
neutralizing it ix
to d2 okay so now the night is coming to
e4 for the blockade right because we
learned that the night is the best
blockading piece now how do we fight
against this blockade look 88 first
because otherwise you would put it we'll
take the pawn rook 88 94 and now Bishop
d8 okay that makes more sense
exactly so the idea is to push f5 and
take the knight out of it efore really
why cannot prevent this so you played c5
attacking the Queen but that made the
Queen even more powerful okay very nice
diagonal battery with a bishop in the
Queen f3
Bishop e7 rook a c1 f5 Quincy for check
King h8 Bishop a4 Queen h6 and now we
start with the tactics Bishop takes e8 f
takes e4 c6
it's very much it's pretty much like
everybody's ignoring everybody's a
threat right take my oh that's okay I'm
just gonna take you I'm not gonna take
him we just gonna play c6 I guess I
think my bishop there's no way I'm
moving it I'm just continuing my plan
he takes f3 i'ma let me do I take here
take here no just to Roxy to
Quinn III check King each one
Bishop CA so it cannot take enough day
because this is losing their the work on
d1
Bishop d7
after
loketh one
d 3 and now the pawns are marching the
mark the march of the pawns
Roxy 3 Bishop takes d7 1 takes e4 what
do we have here let's see how do it
let's count the popular ponds so it
looks like black has a bishop and the
pond versus the rook technically
value-wise why they supposed to be
better but those points are much much
pushed forward this is only one point
and he's got stuck very easily now white
right people Quincy 8 so the idea is to
take the rock and promote but now black
just played Bishop to d8 that's it no
picnic for white but so white move back
but black is the one who is doing the
party now Queen 21
Roxy 1 and now D 2
if it takes we take twice made so he has
to move his rook I'm sorry if we played
Queen to c5 it last chance maybe he's
gonna take the rocket are you gonna
check with him in one move but in this
case black just played rook to g8 so
look how actually looks like a queen and
two pawns or stronger than Queen and two
rooks rook to d1 III a beautiful
position go into c3
and now Queen takes on d1 real takes and
e1 and e2 our last move into
so if somebody asks you was the value of
the of the if is the Queen better than
the pawn 3.6 I'll somebody ask you you
have to say the world depends depends on
the position because here that just
three pawns how better then a real can a
queen so three versus four twelve no
more even thirteen to fourteen
now this one is Levitsky versus Marshall
and again we are going to be playing
Marshall and the nickname for this game
is the shower of gold so if you know so
the story says so it's not it's not
clearly if the legend is if the winning
of the queen think of the shower of gold
coins is true but a marshal said that
the spectators through gold pieces coins
on the board because the move that he
made his last move was so brilliant
now although one reporter says that
actually his wife stated that it will
Caroline that it wasn't the showers of
gold but just a shower of pennies Good
Wife and other guy says that the people
were just paying off their wagers so
let's see what happened why is this last
move at triggered those coins away I
wish I wish I would be thrown some some
coins in my games why not
okay so d4e six and if what if I
whittled suppose to the French defense
Knight to c3
here the black has lots of options
taking a pond and I have six Bishop
before but Marshall chose this variation
c5 which is also an option although I
don't think that this is a one of the
main lines because here white can just
take and create an isolated pawn so
white play Knight of 396 they took on d5
pawn takes on d5 and here I play Bishop
to e2 I think this this move is slightly
passive I would say Bishop to b5 looks
much more natural Bishop e2 Knight of 6
castle Bishop to e7
Bishop g5
gasps OH
now why to calcify so to be honest white
what position looks pretty good because
black cannot capture on c5 immediately
because Bishop takes f6 and then if the
Queen takes back that we're losing all
anybody takes their the the bishop that
we are losing the d5 pawn so black had
to play Bishop e6 first
Knight to d4 Bishop takes e5 Knight
takes on e6 this this move is probably
not one of the best in the in the game
because really a wise advantages about
this isolated pawn and this nice night
we do get two bishops on the other hand
black gets the support of his pawns in
the center Bishop g4 26 bishop HT okay
eight Queen d2 and now Bishop two before
amazingly up just just four or five
moves ago I would choose white but here
I would actually start choosing black
sounding all of black's pieces are very
well positioned there's harmony between
the pieces
in addition why I just took gave his his
bishop probably was scared of 94 rook a
to d1 Queen to c5 getting the Queen out
of this D file and putting some extra
pressure on c3
Queeny to take take Queen takes so black
one upon but why it has actually a way
to regain it but the bill takes on d5 so
the both ways are still fighting 94
Queen h5 rook e 2 e f8
Ruki five and now black starts array
arranging his pieces for the final move
so he starts with the rook to h6 and
surprisingly white he played a very
logical move Queen to g5 which led to
the way to the lost to his loss
because now the combination is real
takes on the HD
but this was not the final move now he
cannot take the rook right because if it
takes the rook on h3 then just Knight f3
forking the king and the Queen so why
play this we'll rope to c5 trying to
counter-attack
so think about this position what is the
blacks best move so hopefully you guys
found the correct move this move as I
said it's called the shovel of gold
after which Marshall got got compass
compensated for his beauty
so are you guys you guys know the move
yeah it is close yes so the corrective
is Queen to g3
sometimes chess is just beautiful so the
queen is attacked three times but no
piece can take it because if it takes
the H pawn
they just made in one move Knight to e2
if they take with the f1 then is going
to be made in two moves a back plate now
if they take the Queen it's still going
to be a maid but just going to take a
bit longer King nightly to check King
h19 takes kim ji-won now actually this
one is not a maid
but now he has to take a take enough for
f1 and the night is coming out to d2
keeping an extra piece so this was our
second most beautiful
yes well and the next game is actually
going to be a recent game which you all
know I'm not going to tell you yet who
is gonna play it so let's see if
somebody can recognize it you're
probably all saw the game you know the
players for sure you're probably over
watching the game
let's see efore c5 Knight to f3
these six
before
pawn takes d4
Knight takes d4
Knight f6
so black is trying to play there the
night off here the you regular movies 93
but because it was a rapid game why
decided to play f3
yes
very good so this is the last game of
the last World Championship in 2016
Magnus Carlsen again still gay Kuryakin
the 16th game so let's see what happened
a 5
Knight to b3 Bishop e7 c4 I like this
move playing against the d5 see for a5
aiming at a for taking out the night
Bishop e3 a four-night c1 mmm mysterious
mover the knife let's see what the night
went after Castle
93
Queen a5
now the bishop might go to d7 but he
might go to e6
so black doesn't really know yet well he
wants to put the bishop he was Queen d2
first 986 Bishop e2 95 Castle now Bishop
d7 now rocked b1 look after c8 be for
brave move ampersand pawn takes the
treadle of before is too strong so black
had to retreat and regroup with his
pieces
Knight to d3 so basically white is
keeping his edge is positional edge
Knight to e6
night before we have a very very nice
outpost here on d5 once we get there
black is going to suffer night before
Bishop c6 that makes no sense right
because now if Knight d5 is we're gonna
take twice with the bishop if the knight
extend Knight takes so we don't want to
give this opportunity for black so I
just played rook F to D 1 C even even
Carlson is watching my videos probably
and following their principles develop
all your pieces first h5 Bishop to f1
very nice waiting move it doesn't really
do much but just in case covering the
king it's also the rapid game so it's
good to give that your opponent some
some time to think
wait this time
h4 so the idea is that now black it was
to play HT in trying to weaken the white
Kings position going to f2
Knight to d7
g3
let's see what was the idea that idea is
that after black played the rook to a3
magnus spotted that the bishop on the
one is not positioned so well behind the
pawns so it'll suppose the bishop to h3
Roxy to 892
okay six exactly so the Knights of a
powerful here Lucky's gonna have
nightmares night before route a 592
almost looks like a draw fur but I guess
reacting felt very confident he did not
play 60 played b6
roadie to
Queen c7
look B to D one exactly well black is
preparing for it
Bishop f8 is leaving all these pieces
saying okay if you come to do you five
at least I'm not gonna get attacked over
here and now cousin just grab this one
in h4
because after 94 it took on takes bishop
takes on d7 queen takes on d7 and grass
who is back then I don't before great
examples how all nights sometimes
actually can be better than the bishops
right there's usually we say that the
bishops are better than the Knights but
not in this case not when we have such
powerful outputs and especially it get
we are going to play against this Bishop
on on their fate but this Bishop on c6
is not so bad rock a3 obviously Kuryakin
is trying to get some counter play from
the Queen side but we exchanged one
night to exchange at the c6 Knight and
now this night comes to b5 obviously we
have some option where to put the night
the idea of night going to be five is
that after clacking - combi three died
came to d4 forking on the other hand if
you don't take on b3 probably going to
lose the d6 pawn at some point
so Quinta see for at least he got two
pawns for for the for the rock but still
this Bishop is not so good actually if
it was black to move here yeah subscribe
black would probably play d5 sometimes
we want to sacrifice a pawn just to
develop a stronger pieces so Carlsen
played Queen e2
Bishop e7 in g2
26
age five
okay three is still not so easy I would
say actually I would say that right now
maybe it's even easier for black to play
because looks like black is is more
active out our King is more exposed but
that's going to change very very fast
because white played rock 2 D 3 root 2
a7 I'm sorry
rope to a to first rope to D to rotate a
hook to D 3 now rock to a 7 ro 2 D 5
Brooke
C 7 so we see lots of rough maneuvering
Queen d2 now after this move probably
white is already eyeing the d6 pawn some
sacrifices
maybe Queen takes a 4
Queen f6
look at five I like the thing that white
is basically playing on all the white
squares everything isn't white like
checkers Queen h4 now we need to try to
get rid of this rook on c7 so Carlson
plays rook c-13 okay seven Queen takes a
for check
King each one the only move otherwise we
are getting Maidan and now black played
Queen 2 f2 almost looks like we are
losing the game because almost we don't
have any defense well we can play root 2
G 1 for example but that's so here
Carlsen find a very beautiful ending for
the game which won him the world title
again rook c8 check now
if Bishop covers that is probably
sacrificing a mate
so black just played King to h8 it
doesn't look like like there's something
going on looks like okay Jay doesn't
work who takes f7 actually we black is
the one looks like they hear that he is
winning right but a really genius move
which was Queen to h6 check
yes usually usually when you see such
such moves on the chest well then you
see that there's a result usually like
wait a second it's probably like this is
not correct and it's probably like it is
a akid to draw something but in this
case yes this was the last one because
the Queen takes the route h8 checkmate
and if the pawn takes the rook takes f7
very very very nice finish for for
Magnus for his for his World
Championship title now we are going to
look at one of the another world
champion which was jose raul kappa
blanka this game is played in 1914
between Berenstain white makeup of
Blanca was playing black was played in
Moscow now kappa skål Blancas a last
move is one of the most famous chess gay
chess moves in the history of chess so
let's see
d4 d5 c4 e6 we have a Queens gambit
declined the board was very popular at
that age
Bishop g5 castle III 9b d7 Roxy one b6c
takes d5 it takes d5 24-bit should be
seven basically this is all theory
Bishop e6 Bishop takes a 626 C 5
Bishop takes f6 Knight takes f6
D takes e5 we take C fire and castle so
that is a Bernstein who is playing with
white this position is not bad he
catered for kappa blanka he carried
those two weak pawns the position is
probably pretty equal but now black
weight kappa blanka kappa played Queen
to b6
now if white exchanges the Queen then
whether we have a nice pawn chain not so
weak anymore
and our work is going to be much more
active so why decide to retreat with
Queen to e2 c for rook F to D 1 F to d8
94 okay so steel looks like white is
doing everything right
black block it in the two ponds put the
two rooks in the correct spots so let's
see what went wrong Bishop before b3
rook a to c8 b takes e4 d tasty for
Roxy - maybe BT was the weakening move
looks like some some pieces are hanging
right now Bishop takes c3 rocked AC 395
okay so this pawn starts to get very
very dangerous
exactly yeah I don't want to block the
pawns of the rocks sometimes sometimes
you do the knight Knight comes into
attack that's not not a good idea now
why can't he take on c4 yeah simple fork
so white went back rock c2 c3 roadie to
see one wrote to c5 Knight to b3 roof to
see 694 Rock to c7 so the real master is
know how to repeat moves just a little
bit of a change right to b5 work to c5
and now white made a huge mistake so
going back they took the pollen c3
Knight takes 23 rotation c3
real takes on c3 real takes on c3 so how
does black win here think about it for a
few seconds now
of course not Queen B 1 was if Queen B 1
then Y can play Queen to f1 and the rook
to d1 does not work
Roxy 8 exactly so here this does not
work but the most beautiful law is Queen
to be to a nice distraction
so the queen is over all she has to
defend the first rank and the rook she
can't she could try but then we just
take the rook and check me this game was
played in 1923 between savage and nimza
which means which is probably my
favorite player of all time especially
from learning for him the game got his
name the immortal zoos one game now we
know about the immortal game right which
was the King's gambit but this is the
mode called a modern zoos one game and
you will see why so again they're
playing black black rules today d4
Knight of 6 c4 e6
9 f3 of course names of each playing
black plays the names of each g3 they
should be 7 yes yeah basically the bf to
be 6 it's only the names of each one but
Bishop a6 is another variation I
actually play Bishop a6 sometimes
sometimes Bishop e7 it's a matter of
taste but yes both of the moves up very
popular and both are played Bishop g2
Bishop e7 Knight to c3 Castle castle d5
so a very similar structure to the game
that we saw before 95 a very famous
maneuver where the knife comes three
five pins the d5 pawn c6 yeah
now white took on on d5 naturally it's
the best choice because I really like
that the fact that the bishop is turned
off so this video gives eases blacks
game why play Bishop to f4
a six
Roxy 1 now b5 just getting some space
now it's also dangerous sometimes
because you might get all those
witnesses on dark squares but we I don't
see exactly how maybe the nine can jump
to from d3 to c5 why faith Queen to b3
so so far so good so far so good
96 nine takes is 6
Bishop takes c6
a ch3 that's a little bit of a strange
move to me maybe this was the first
mistake
Queen d7
King h2
9h five yeah Bishop d2 so the idea now
we can't play f6 and E 5 because we are
going to weaken the d5 pawn idea is to
play f5 trying to play f4
Quinn d1b for so suddenly black is the
one who gets the Kanto Plain and I think
again that to happen because of those
two moves HT King h2 is really a waste
of time exactly night night the night is
going home to sleep this should be five
ro g'wan Bishop disease the game for
black is super easy
efore
F takes e4 named Zoe is sacrificing full
peace to get active pieces this rook is
a beast
25 rook a to f8 g into h 1r o to f5
Queen to e3 Bishop to d3 so black is is
like a pipe Python right is suffocating
his opponent rook now the thread is
rookie to write to capture the Queen
rook to e1 and now comes the final move
in the game I'm going to give you a few
seconds to think about it if rocked a g2
then rook tasty too after a queen to g1
now remember I said this is called the
mortal zoobank game think about how can
white move in this position so his last
move was eight six
that's like passing exactly now why why
is it why is this move so strong because
why there's no move see I cannot move
the bishop right as I'm gonna lose this
night
this is defended if eight we can try to
play eight three but then I can even
play a five I can't move this row
because rook e 2 I can't move this rope
I cannot move the bishop basically the
threat is also root 2 F 3 so why there's
a piece up for a point just regular
position when the he resigns because
this is going to be my last my best last
move and actually I think it's actually
going to be better than H 6 I think this
game is actually going to tap that going
to the top of my list
exactly ok I'm going to do it quickly
now this game actually I played again
against Grandmaster Buda Grunfeld and
because I won this game that was part of
the tournament that gave me the my final
I am norm so it was very important for
me to win now I was white and I played
efore a5 and I played Bishop to c4 so
the bishops opening night of 6d 390 693
Bishop e7 the idea with the Bishop
opening is that now it allows you to
play this move f4 it's kind of like the
playing the save style of the Kings
gambit scheme geezer you're still there
for but you are sacrificing your pawn on
f4
so point of all d6 night of t castle and
now a very important move f5 to block it
to block all of these pieces 95 so he's
trying to push with c6 and d5 I played
Bishop e3 Knight takes pawn takes d5
blacks playing very well is trying to
explore the center because my king is
still not castle and therefore I played
Queen - E - it's quiet move hoping that
he was gonna play d4 he played the rook
e8 and now g4 that's why I couldn't
attack now obviously to take on on g4 is
quite dangerous because you can lose
your point if i ro G 1 so you played
Bishop to b4 black still looks pretty
good
Bishop d2 now if you take on e4 I will
take with the pawn power of E and the D
file is going to be controlled by white
after I don't cast or put the rock on d1
so he played d4 Knight to d1 bishop
tasty to 98 0
97 to prevent g5i played well if I push
immediately you can take and then Queen
h4 so I played Knight f3 first night of
fate roll rolled the h1 right go into d6
Queen to h2 mysterious move just to make
sure attacking the pawn 25 the player to
enter with a queen on the h-file a5 now
here I realized that actually a four was
a big threat so I had to play Queen d2
to go back b6 night of to now what I
like about this game is that I'm not
revealing where am i casting maybe to
the Kings side and the Queen side Bishop
d7 g 5a for now I have to take bishop
takes and I played King to e2
very nice for collecting the rocks
25 betray I have to defend a seat to
pawn bishop c6 Knight to g4 97 h5 rook
takes a one rook takes a one rook e8
take Bishop takes on a eight yeah
actually the bishop is supposed to be
good against the the pawns which are on
white squares but really the pawn chain
is very very strong
so here finally a breakthrough g6 it's
time to mate
it's mating time HT is g6 now I could
take with the f-bomb but I decided to
take the H pawn f6 and now one of my
best moves came to d1
defending the pawn on c2 and preparing
to invade with my queen that's at the
end King f8 is trying to escape go into
h2 Queen to e8 now if I play king queen
to h8 he's going to come to effect and
exchange Queens which I don't want to do
so I played Queen to h7
go into f8 92 95
so how do we win this position so let's
go back here so I played 92 just in case
if he had I was just in case black wants
to sacrifice on e4 but how do we win
this how do we penetrate this position
it's not so easy so from here the game
ended in two moves two moves well if I
take only five he just takes and f6
Queen takes of six so the hint for this
position is number one try to focus on
his weakness try to figure out what's
his weakness and how could you not a kit
number two is how to improve your pieces
which piece does not do much yes the
knight on g4 where would you like to put
the night
well it's 96 then yeah that's correct I
don't have to take it and even if I do I
don't know if I'm winning well yes
because then there's just seven my
problem is that night h6 doesn't do much
so where is the weakness exactly so I
played nine f2 now blacks toto that I'm
just I'm just gonna repeat whoops so he
paid Knight to a six so I assumed that
he expected me to play Knight g4 and and
to make a draw but no now I revealed my
secret plan Knight to h1
yeah
and once he saw this move resigned yeah
because there is not enough time there's
not enough time I think that instead of
night to a six he could play
let's see some how to bring the night
here so one two three four so one two
three four moves and I'm doing one two
three I think it was in time
so if night be seven instead
I'm sorry
ninety-eight
but he stories I'm gonna repeat pose and
after night each one well yes there is
no way to defend the g7 thorn after the
pawn falls so does the game yeah but my
game finished with Knight each one I've
never seen any game in history which
ended with the move Knight h1 so this is
the top of my list and hopefully use as
well thank you so much
[Music]